masks and face coverings the must-have
accessory of 2020 not exactly a decision
driven by fashion of course but as
lockdowns are being lifted many people
are ditching their masks not so fast
says the government here in Berlin who
are telling people to keep covered up
wherever the minimum distance cannot be
guaranteed in public life masks aren't
important and from today's perspective
still indispensable means to keep the
infection numbers low and to protect our
fellow human beings and ourselves so
whether on the bus in the subway or in
retail the obligation to wear masks
should remain the Chancellor herself is
being seen out and about in a mask when
she can't socially distance from others
one of the issues to arise from this
requirement to wear a mask is the number
of people who were not wearing them
correctly the two main culprits seemed
to be the chin mask which basically
defeats the point of having a mask on in
the first place and the free nose er
which seen as a mask to be effective has
to cover both mouth and nose also
renders its pretty useless that's
prompted Berlin's public transport
provider to get creative when it comes
to convincing passengers to cover up
correctly and it's those that leave
their noses exposed that they're
targeting through one of the great
commuter bugbears and talking of course
about the smell of other passengers
Berlin public transport have form when
it comes to their advertising during
Fashion Week they've joked around the
city's hedonistic reputation that
they're happy for passengers to be
wearing any clothes at all
and that the German capital's public
transport would pick you up even when
your own mother wouldn't do Berliners
think enough people in the German
capital are wearing masks and doing it
correctly I am a tourist here from
Dusseldorf and here in
there are not so many masks compared to
just read off well we had more rules on
that Chantal I believe I think in Berlin
definitely it's sufficient it depends on
the country and the culture but here in
Berlin it works pretty good it depends
on the location on public transport it
works well but sometimes people do not
wear it properly on a correct way
Germans have to learn because we get
fines for me to put them on properly
Shenzhen estimize I think that most of
the people are wearing it right but
sometimes you see them doing this that
makes no sense
but most of doing it right yeah as far
as I can see most are wearing masks
but some of them are not doing it right
you can see their nose sticking out but
on public transport most are wearing it
without a vaccine Corona is going to be
with us for a while yet and as long as
it is masks and face coverings whether
we like it or not are going to be part
of our daily lives Peter Oliver RT
Berlin
you